INTRO:
Do you know who’s
the third-largest semiconductor company in the
world? The first two are relatively easy to guess,
they’re Nvidia and TSMC. But what about the
third one? Some good guesses would be Intel,
Qualcomm, and TI, but the answer is actually
a company called ASML. Currently, ASML boasts
a market cap of just under $300 billion coming
in at the 29th largest publicly traded company
in the world. To put that in perspective, their
market cap is currently over twice that of AMD.
Aside from a behemoth market cap, in terms of
semiconductor wafer front-end equipment market
share, ASML was the second largest single
market share holder coming in at 15.4%,
only beaten out by Applied Materials. Yet most
people have never even heard about ASML. So,
here’s the story of ASML and how they
became the $300 billion shadow chip company.
SHED OPERATION:
Taking a look back, the story of ASML dates back
to the Netherlands to the year 1984. At the time,
many chip companies were trying to commercialize
a manufacturing technique called photolithography.
Photolithography is the process of using light in
order to produce a thin protective film. In terms
of semiconductors, the thin film is generally
used to protect select portions of silicon wafers.
This technique actually has roots that date
back as far as 1820 to a french inventor
named Nicephore Niepce, but it wasn’t till the
1970s that semiconductor companies really started
to leverage this process. In the meantime, two
relatively small companies named Royal Philips
Electronics and Advanced Semiconductor Materials
International, or ASMI, felt that they were being
left behind with this process. So, they decided to
make a joint venture called Advanced Semiconductor
Materials Lithography or ASML. Despite being
founded by two existing companies, the early days
of ASML weren’t glamorous by any means. Philips
cleaned out a shed behind one of their offices and
that became the new headquarters of ASML. Over the
next several months, ASML focused on developing
and integrating photolithography. And given that
they weren’t inventing a new process from scratch,
it didn’t take them too long to come out with
their first system called the PAS 2000 stepper.
If you’ve ever wondered what the
big machines in chip factories are,
well, this is one of them. Anyway, with their
first product up and running, the parent companies
decided to up their investments into ASML. By
1985, ASML upgraded to a newly built office and
factory located in Veldhoven. Their employee count
also grew to a solid 100 employees. Soon after,
ASML came out with their second product in 1986
which was the PAS 2500 stepper. As ASML’s product
lineup grew, they started to form partnerships
with established companies such as the lens
manufacturer Carl Zeiss. Philips also helped ASML
open locations in Taiwan and the United States,
but all was not good. Here’s the thing, while
ASML was churning out great products, it was
nothing particularly new or innovative. There
was already plenty of comparable solutions from
established semiconductor companies, and customers
saw no reason to take a gamble with a startup.
So, ASML had high expenses and little revenue. To
make things worse, one of the parent companies,
ASMI, would call it quits in the mid-1980s. They
sold their 50% stake in ASML to Philips and left
the startup. While Philips purchased the stake
from ASMI, they weren’t that optimistic about ASML
either. Philips’ investors were starting
to suggest that ASML was a lost cause
and that Philips should cut losses as soon
as possible. Considering the dire situation,
ASML’s executives reached out to
Philips’ board member Henk Bodt,
and they were able to come to one final deal.
Philips would back one more round of funding,
but if that didn’t work or wasn’t enough,
they were going to shut down ASML. Oftentimes,
it’s when the stakes are the highest that we
produce the best results, and this couldn’t
be truer for ASML as they came out with a
breakthrough platform called the PAS 5500.
BREAKTHROUGH:
The PAS 5500 boasted industry-leading productivity
and resolution which motivated many customers to
give the startup a shot, and this is exactly
what ASML needed to finally turn a profit.
Despite the positive progress though, Philips was
still looking to get out of ASML. So, in 1995,
they took ASML public on the Amsterdam and New
York Stock exchanges at roughly a billion-dollar
valuation. Philips sold half of their stake at
IPO, and they slowly sold off the rest of their
stock over the next couple of years. And with
that, Philips was completely out of the business,
but that was ok as they had already done their
part in keeping ASML alive. Ever since then,
ASML has expanded into 3 other categories aside
from lithography which include the track division,
the thermal division, and the special applications
division. Starting with the track division, this
part of the company focuses on producing equipment
that can coat, develop, and bake light-sensitive
materials onto a wafer’s surface. Moving onto the
thermal division, this sector produces furnaces
and deposition systems. The furnaces are used to
heat up wafers during the manufacturing process,
and the deposition systems are
used to remove chemical vapors.
And finally, the special applications division
is basically just a customization department.
This sector customizes products produced by the
other departments to meet customer needs. For
example, one customer might need larger furnaces
in order to manufacture larger batches of wafers.
Similarly, another customer might need smaller
furnaces and so on and so forth. Looking at these
divisions, you probably realized that ASML isn’t
actually a chip manufacturer themselves. Instead,
they primarily deal with manufacturing
chip-producing equipment. So, they’re basically
the top of the semiconductor food chain. When you
buy an iPhone, Apple turns around and gets Foxconn
to manufacture the smartphone. Foxconn then turns
around and calls up TSMC to source the chips.
And then TSMC turns around and calls up ASML
to get their equipment. So, though ASML is
mostly invisible to the public, without them,
basically nothing would take place. Anyway,
going back to the late 1990s, the dot-com bubble
was in full force, and ASML leveraged the bubble
to raise money and continue innovation. They were
no longer innovating to catch up though, now, they
were innovating to lead the market. In 1996, ASML
introduced their step and scan system which blew
away the competition. This system was capable of
producing 100 wafers per hour which was nearly
double the standard 60 wafers per hour. Seeing
this, the US Department of Energy invited ASML to
expand its presence in the US through the Extreme
Ultraviolet LLC program. As the name suggests,
the program aimed to upgrade traditional
photolithography to use extreme ultraviolet
light. ASML did end up figuring out this
technology and customers far preferred it.
And by the end of the century, ASML grew to
be the 2nd largest semiconductor supplier
in the world. Unfortunately though, this was
the highest point they would see for a decade.
CLIFF DIVE:
By now, we’ve discussed
the dot-com crash so many times on this channel
that I’m sure you guys know what went down. Years
of exuberant speculation and hopium finally
came crashing down in the early 2000s which
crushed the entire stock market and especially
tech companies, and ASML was by no means immune
to this. ASML was expecting a slowdown as the chip
industry often operates in boom and bust cycles,
but the bust was far worse than they anticipated.
ASML had told their investors that 2001 sales
should be roughly the same as 2000, so they were
tempering expectations. But, by March of 2001,
it became clear that even matching sales was going
to be impossible. ASML froze hiring and focused on
just completing existing contracts, but companies
were pulling out of contracts left and right.
For example, Intel canceled a $100 million order.
By the end of 2001, net sales had nearly halved in
comparison to 2000 from 3.1 billion euros to 1.84
billion euros. ASML also put in a painful $422.4
million loss. And as you would guess, the stock
graph didn’t look much better. By October of 2002,
ASML stock was down a full 90% from their peak
in 2000. Despite the harsh decline, ASML actually
faired a lot better than the rest of the industry
given that ASML did eventually recover and put
in new all-time highs. But, back in the early
2000s, things were only getting worse for ASML.
At the end of 2001, Nikon filed a patent
infringement lawsuit against ASML. Nikon
claimed that ASML had infringed upon 7 of their
patents relating to microlithography equipment.
A couple of months later in April of 2002, ASML
countersued Nikon suggesting that it was Nikon
that infringed upon ASML’s patents. This didn’t
work out too well for ASML though as the two
eventually came to a settlement where ASML paid
Nikon $87 million. Fortunately though, things
finally started to turn around for ASML after
this lawsuit. ASML had started shipping out their
TWINSCAN systems which offered a revolutionary
dual-stage technology. Instead of measuring and
aligning a wafer and then exposing it, Twinscan
systems could do both tasks simultaneously. This
technology allowed customers to produce smaller
chips faster and more efficiently than ever
before. Also, do you remember the EUV technology
that ASML started working on in the late 1990s?
Well, they shipped their first EUV lithography
machine called the NXE 3100 in 2010, and they’ve
been a leader in EUV lithography ever since.
Aside from rolling out new technologies, ASML
was slowly acquiring companies in the background.
For example, in 2001, they acquired the Silicon
Valley Group for $1.6 billion. Similarly, in 2007,
they acquired Brion technologies for $270 million.
And in 2013, they acquired Cymer for
$2.5 billion. All these acquisitions
allowed ASML to return to their dot-com peak
by mid-2013, but ASML was just getting started.
ASML TODAY:
Over the past 5 to 7 years, ASML has been doing
better than ever before because the semiconductor
industry has been doing than ever before due to
three main reasons starting with AMD. In 2017, AMD
introduced their Ryzen line of processors which
made gaming computers more affordable and powerful
than ever before. This led to more casual gamers
entering the PC master race which substantially
increased demand for CPUs and GPUs. Around the
same time, Bitcoin was making its first move
towards to moon rising to $20,000. By this point,
it already didn’t make sense to use GPUs to mine
bitcoin. But, it did make sense to use GPUs to
mine ethereum. And given how profitable ethereum
mining was, miners basically bought up the entire
GPU market. Seeing how much demand there was
for GPUs, Nvidia decided to significantly hike
prices with the launch of the 2000 series, and
these prices have never gone down. And finally,
to make things even worse, the pandemic brought
with it the supply shortage which has just made
it even easier for suppliers to hike prices
and increase profit margins. Considering
this semiconductor boom, I don’t think you’d be
too surprised to hear that ASML’s revenues and
profits have grown severalfold. In the mid-2010s,
ASML was pulling in $6 to $7 billion in revenue
every year. In the most recent 12 month period,
they pulled in over $20 billion. Similarly,
in the mid-2010s, ASML was pulling in about
$1.5 billion in net profit every year.
In the most recent 12 months period, ASML
pulled in $6.4 billion in net profit. So,
things are going quite well for ASML right now,
but as we saw in 2000, it doesn’t take that long
for things to turn around. The supply shortage is
not going to last forever, cryptocurrencies are
moving towards proof of stake which eliminates
the need for GPUs and ASICs, and it’s just a
matter of time until the new influx of gamers due
to Ryzen starts to stagnate. So, the next decline
is just a matter of when not if. But, regardless
of what decline comes around, it’s clear that ASML
isn’t going anywhere anytime soon. And for all of
our sakes, that’s probably a good thing. Where you
guys familiar with ASML? Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re thankful for ASML.
And of course, consider checking out our
international channels to watch our videos
in other languages and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.